hi Alan welcome Alan Alda we're in break
and I see we have three minutes left and
I see Alan Alda walk up I'm so
frustrated that we're not on the air so
I'm sorry to make you wait and we are on
right now to say that too
welcome to the show thank you very much
I liked your book I haven't read all
because we got it kind of late the book
is called if you wonder if I understood
you when I have this look on my face and
I literally never read anything written
about people focusing and listening and
paying attention kind of the way you're
talking about me but the interesting
thing is that what I found out while I
was working on this was that the person
talking has to do more listening than
the person listening does that make
sense it does make sense because you
talked about well if I'm talking and
then I'm not only thinking about what
you're saying I'm just saying about my
next statement and then people just kind
of like no one is really listening to
each other right not only that if I'm
not thinking about how you're getting
what I'm saying then I'm not really
working on getting you to understand it
I'm only working on how I'm saying it is
a big difference between what I say and
what you get and what's the point of
saying it if you don't get it yeah it's
a really a reversal of what we think of
as listening sail or communicating so
you're waiting for responses to see yeah
you're reading the other person's face
your body language and you're trying to
figure out what's their state of mind
what are they thinking what are they
feeling and the funny thing is we don't
really take each other in much I mean
I've been talking to you now for 30
seconds I'm just noticing your eyes he's
unpleasant to look at is it I know
that's not up until then he had just
sort of a blank piece of skin over how
do you recall if you're talking to
somebody and you find yourself zoning
out which we all do how do you get
yourself to refocus and go all right I
got to listen to what this person like I
start looking at them it's a mean it's
every time I do that this is really
amazing every time I do it I realize I
hadn't been seeing them a second before
really and when I start really seeing
what
you know the shape of your eyebrows that
little crease you have between your eyes
yeah you saw that now yeah okay won't go
away sometimes I try to make it it's
because I've stalled for so many years
and I can't get it to go away well all
of a sudden I'm seeing your book table
communicating so I noticed this now and
now all of a sudden that actually has a
change in the way I speak it's at the
sound of my voice to look on my face it
noticing you letting you into my my
field of vision changes me and then that
in turn changes you because you see it
in me there's a dynamic inter relation
that's really interesting that happens
just by seeing each other
yeah I'm really paying attention in kind
of you so you talk about being in
somebody letting like having this moment
with a person where you're kind of
allowing yourself to be in their space
you're connecting I forget how you wrote
it but it was really smart and it made
perfect sense I'm not doing it justice I
forget how I wrote it okay good
it's got to be tough for you though
because I would think in your position
you're like the things that I've done in
my life yeah odds are are much more
interesting than the person that I'm
talking to tell Maya I know and maybe
I'm just I have done to score really
high on the humility scale as you can
tell from that legend but I I really am
interested in other people I find it's
very often somebody who I think at first
claims oh this is going to be a hard
dinner because this person is not going
to be interesting so sometimes I say
what are you passionate about and that
not what you do for a living or what you
know what how you spend your what are
you really passionate about all of a
sudden they come out with stuff that's
really interesting
and we have a conversation except
there's one time he said what are you
passionate about and she said well I
like golf oh oh how bad we're going to
give her a passion injection gotta--you
a euphemism for something no that's
weird games passionate about passion
injection
and you talked about - it's funny cuz
I've been such a fan for so long and you
talked about I took a photo with you on
time years ago and I'm like oh he
doesn't look like he enjoyed himself in
the photo and then I read something in
here will you talk about you went to a
dentist and he did something to you yeah
what was it that he can you explain what
that dentists do if you put your tongue
between the top of your front teeth and
the lip there's that little tissue there
right yeah that's called the freedom or
the frenum and he cut mine because he
had some new man I don't think I'm just
feeling for it I don't think I have
barely any left he said he said he had a
new invention a new operation you wanted
to do a my my gum and in the process he
cut this little tissue if I lip drooped
down like a like a drape and so I'm
making a movie a couple of weeks later
and the Camerons that came over so I
thought you're supposed to smile in that
shot I said I did only know you were
sneering and I looked in the mirror and
there was his big I had a smile ectomy I
really can't do it anymore
so it's in my smile is a little altered
I had to like consciously pull back my
cheeks to get his fine well couldn't
even what he supposed to a two-part a
two-part procedure yeah there was
supposed to be two parts I can't
remember if I let him into my mouth
again I just love why I said that
blanked out so you and you talked about
the reason that was important was
because you speak about how you didn't
communicate he was a shitty
communicators did neither one of us
communicated well all he said he had the
knife in front of my face and he said
now there'll be some tethering and I
stopped down into what he meant
tethering I said what'd he mean should
tethering I said what would was
tethering to tethering tethering to get
really pissed and that's all he said and
I was I was over the age of fifty but I
should have had this strength that
wherewithal to say put the knife down
put the scalpel down and tell me what
you're talking about right and I didn't
and he cut and boom there
when my smile for at least for a while I
got some my smile back yeah but that's
funny that you're Alan Alda and even
even you have those moments of like what
like don't think you feel like a little
kid in the doctor's chair just not not
able to just talk to him as another dog
oh wait I want to know what you're doing
yeah see I need I need practice and what
this book teaches which which I got
while I was writing and I learned a lot
more about about how to take care of
myself in a communication but I don't
know I'm Alan old until people tell me
really I feel like you you don't know
y'all about that a second ago from you
then you'll forget again yeah right do
you think it is it is it generational
because the the stereotypes of
Millennials is that they're kind of
self-obsessed and this culture of using
your phone so much has left them with
the inability to connect the way
previous generations could do you see
that when you're when you're I don't
know if the word is researching but you
know you're searching that well you know
we've taught at the Center for
communicating science that I helped
start at Stony Brook University we
across the country and in other
countries we've trained about 8,000
scientists and doctors of all ladies
some of them are senior scientists some
of them are graduate students so we've
got Millennials and everybody else and I
don't think this communication problem
is confined to any one generation I
think we all tend it's such a curious
thing we all tend to be preoccupied with
what we want to say not how the other
person is taking it no matter no matter
what the age is but no matter how good
we are at having fun with another person
it's it's a weird thing we're social
animals and yet we avoid socializing
with each other in a real deep way it's
just kind of 10 it's easier to be
superficial about it but if we want to
communicate something if we want to get
a better job we have to go talk to the
boss we got to see what the boss where
the boss is before we bring up this
really difficult subject and as we bring
it up we got to bring it up in a way
that the boss can hear it yeah and be
with us
without that whole thing you're talking
about that feeling somebody out that
whole kind of seeing in the moment yeah
I mean you're like an old-school improv
guy which is kind of you
started doing improv ice-t-- yeah that's
the only training I ever had as an actor
and where it was it was it with Paul
sills we were on the stage at Second
City but it wasn't Second City stuff who
wasn't comedy improv so my was viola
Spolin this theatre games which are not
intended for comedy I mean you can use
them to get comedy and there's a lot of
laughing because it's the laughing that
you get from seeing spontaneity you know
that makes you giggle when something
when they when when the unconscious
suddenly comes to the surface it's funny
when it when it kind of feels alive and
you know it's happening right there but
that's just more like joy than than
laughter you know it's not no jokes so
what we would what I teach and the
people I work with teach improvisation
for communication purposes it's so that
we you can establish this connection
with another person because you can't be
you can't do improv unless you're
connected and the early exercises and
improv put you in in sync with the other
person you're you're almost one unit you
know the whole yes--and thing the byword
of a lot of improvisers yes and the
basis of yes and it's you you've got to
make your partner look good you can't
take it away from your partner your
partner says you're in the Senior
Partners is look at the water down there
and if you say that's not water that's
the floor yeah you'll get a laugh out of
that but that's the end of the scene and
you've just made your partner look bad
right
on the contrary you'd say you take what
you get from your partner whatever it is
however weird it is look at that water
down there you say yeah let's jump in
yes let's jump in and let's catch onto
that whale out there now all of a sudden
you've added to what your partner said
and you and you each are contributing to
the other that's what a communication
can be so when you start with who would
you started and when did you go into
comedy improv from there like when you
start to relax first I did I was it was
a very interesting progress I really saw
the importance of
real training and improv because the
first improvisation that kid was in a
cabaret in the basement of a hotel in
Hyannisport was the same hotel that John
Kennedy was doing his press conferences
during during that summer we were there
was at the same time I always all around
here he would do he it was in the summer
he would do his press conferences in the
morning and upstairs in the hotel at
night I would play Kennedy and the mock
press conference and the same reporters
would come to both I'd ask you about
questions about me the same questions
they'd asked him but hadn't been in the
papers yet so I didn't know what they
were telling true improvisation um
prodding as Kennedy to the same
reporters yeah it's really weird
yeah that is weird so that we did the
two-hour show and the second hour was
total spot improvisation no preparation
whatsoever they had they give us
suggestions from the audience headlines
and things like that that was just what
I would call guts improvising there was
no preparation for it except you had a
few characters you could call on you
know but a year or two after that I
worked with Paul sills on this more
basic kind of improvising to viola
Spolin Spolin invented a long time ago
like 6070 years ago uh knowledge I ask
you who are some of those guys who are
to it back and back and I was um Diana
sands was dead now and Reni Santoni who
I got a they were extremely talented
people but you probably haven't heard of
most of them okay they just feel around
at that time it not yes right now Jerry
Kennedy no I never met him I did him but
I never met her how great is it to like
when we hear scientists right we this
information that they have is
information that we should all have so
we kind of look at them as they're these
geniuses they're to teach us because we
don't have any of this information how
great is it to take information that you
have and a skill set that you have and
be able to teach these people that
generally we will look at that as it's a
nice question you know what's nice about
it is almost all of them are eager to to
get better what they do
and they accept the idea that I have
some experience in the field they don't
have experience in and they see it
working right they see one another in a
workshop they see one another struggle
to be understood and sometimes fellow
scientists don't understand what they're
saying I mean that that's a revelation
sometimes you know it's a really sad
statistic is that we sometimes ask them
when you go to a conference and you hear
papers presented by people in your field
how much of it do you understand
and they say often they say about 20%
wow that's not good do you think they're
embarrassed I'm sorry you think they're
embarrassed to ask what is that loom
because I want to look stupid well
they're in the audience the person is
not reading from a paper or talking and
and they don't you mean they go there to
learn something so then it's not that
they could not that it's that something
they haven't heard before it's that
they're there they're there they're
there to learn but they can't follow the
person who's telling them about it even
though it's in their own field yeah as
an onlooker you want to say well I don't
understand what they're talking about
but I'm assuming the industry does yeah
right
and it's shocking how things get just
clogged up in a logjam and all kinds of
communication in business and in
personal relations I don't know if you
got to this section from the book about
husbands and wives lovers parents and
children I mean all of that is jammed up
with with not good communication we all
have that in our lives we recognize it
you know why are you talking to me in
that tone of voice yeah that kind of
thing are you a good communicator with
stuff like that like are you good if
your wife is a man you wrote the book he
better be quiet but I don't buy my wife
is home laughing though oh yeah
is she are you good at going hey look
I'm really sorry or are you bad at that
I used to be terrible at it you are yeah
and the kind of I'm sorry what that says
I have I have a written excuse you know
if you're sorry there's no excuse right
right I'm sorry but I you know I had to
do it I had to do it the way you were
behaving
I'm sorry why I'm sorry you were like
this isn't weird though those arguments
you get into it with someone you're
dating or married to it's like this
those furious power driven arguments and
nothing it's like I don't ever hear what
the other person saying they're just
angry and I want them to feel that is
you know what's interesting is what what
this kind of approach tends to do is
build up your ability of empathy and
empathy is not sympathy it's not
compassion it's just it's just a tool
it's just knowing what's happening in
their head and if you know that and if
you also want to use it to the advantage
of both of you and not just to your
advantage
then you can use empathy to say oh wait
I think I get what's going on here I
think I understand what she was really
after and how I didn't meet her
expectations and maybe we can work that
out
or you can say I you know use it against
her and and make her even unhappier yeah
yeah that's that sometimes I'm sure
that's the more fun option but it's
weird with embassy to like there's a
weird part of me at times that will
think oh no that's a that's weakness to
be empathetic nothing we it's some some
people define empathy that way I don't
use it that way because I don't like the
way I see you're working in
communication is it's just a tool and
you can build it up and the more you
build it up the more it gives you a
chain it actually has made me feel that
other people are less annoying Oh see
understand so we're the annoying
behavior is coming from and I say yeah I
see okay I don't have to get upset about
it's not directed at me they're going
through something they're awful or that
I said having troubled at home they're
sick you know what it whatever it is I
got in a taxi once and I was I was
getting made at him and then I really
she had to get someplace and get to the
bathroom like well that that's kind of
more important than what I'm worried
about here yeah that's a nice way for
you to look at because I would always
think that my trip is more important to
have again right I'm awful but the poor
guy he saw me he saw me helping him find
where to go which ordinarily would get
me upset because I used to drive a cab
and I thought it was my responsibility
to know
to get there so I when I started helping
him find where where we were on the map
because I got out my cell phone I was
getting really loose in ecstasy of
empathy yeah you are now involved
completely I said you know nobody gets
in this cab is nice like you I'm taking
you exactly to re-election no-go drop me
off a block away you can go you can go
to the gas station at 96th Street no no
I'm taking you where you're gone now the
guy is devoting his kidneys to Europe
with mental illness in your family right
yeah my mother was schizophrenic so does
that change the way you look at
communication because like when you have
that kind of mental illness from your
mom there are behaviors that you have to
you know you don't wanna use the word
excuse but you have to at least say well
yeah that's an illness that you see that
was first of all in those days nobody
talked about it my father and I both
suffered from her mental illness and
neither one of us would ever talk about
it didn't even connect together no I
never once Wow and so I wasn't as aware
that she was mentally ill as I was aware
that I wasn't getting mothering from her
and I didn't like her for it and
sometimes I hated her I really needed
what's in this book I needed to see what
was underneath and it was only later in
life when you know before she died I
realized that she couldn't help it right
and and I tried to take care of her as
much as I could and make up for how I
felt about her earlier and I didn't want
to feel guilty after she died I wanted
to put as much I put more into it than
was reasonable I thought because I
really wanted to ease her way out when
she had a hard time with fades very
painful to be mentally you and your dad
you never even like your dad would be a
massive you sometimes and you never even
as adults later in life had any type of
what would that life if things went
crazy
how would you to address it would it
just be uh you know it's your mom we
just cope with it you know she she was
also alcoholic and paranoid and would
have really gone I should tear the
drapes down and scream all night
and it was a very difficult childhood
interestingly gave me the put me in the
habit of reading her really carefully
because I had to figure out whether I
was getting reality from her or just her
reality and so I think that helped me as
an actor and a writer because I am more
observant and I look for what's under
the surface maybe it helped me with the
working on this book you can like you
know you can always get better and I get
better at all these things as I worked
on it because you're trained in talking
to somebody right and finding out
exactly where they are and exactly it's
because you know how you're going to be
affected by exactly what type of place
they're in right yeah it was it was a it
was a real interesting training ground
what at what point in your childhood did
you realize this is not typical if I
like a lot of times I've it's in our
house would we never in I did never knew
it wasn't typical when people it was
interesting into my teens and early 20s
when people say oh I love my mother so
much I'd say really like so I thought
everybody had a difficult did you feel
guilty that I'm a person too what what
is this a nice mother would yeah did you
feel guilty not like here
pardon did you feel guilty not like here
I can't remember I think I think it was
sort of a scab I had you know protected
me how old are you and she passed away I
was in like 50s also she saw you go out
to success and you do what you did you
know did she think you weren't smiling
at her because that was the same time
frankly it didn't play into the paranoia
to it yeah like what's he really
thinking about he's going to kill me
he's frowning at me do you have any of
that do how did you get any of that a
lot of times it's hereditary did any of
that I don't think so but watch your
step
yeah well if you don't ever mean if you
don't think you have it at least we know
the paranoia didn't kick in right yeah
well we know you never paranoid about
yourself it's always there's always
other people what are they saying my
leave your room yeah yeah did you guys
almost to just I have to ask you a watch
one has one mask question really did you
guys almost really get canceled in the
first season or after the first season
excuse me no I don't think so but we
were at the bottom of the ratings list I
used to tell people were in the top 78
and it was only when women into reruns
and people had seen the other shows
already they tried out ours in that
first season of reruns that we got said
to build a notice and in the second year
we had a real audience and after people
not familiar after season 3 I think
MacLean Stephenson decided to leave and
do you remember when that happened going
like what are you doing this is things
are just getting good he was making a
mistake and we ran into him on an
escalator a couple of years later and he
said I really am sorry I did oh wow
he was blinded by an offer from another
network it said they were going to put
millions into his career and he'd give
him a show of his own show hello Larry
yeah and it just on the face of it if
you're doing something as groundbreaking
as Matt masters there really is no other
show that you can think of that would be
something to take a bet on
yeah and it's one of those things where
in that moment I guess you just you
today and what they did was so amazing
with him because they left no room for
him to come back they were mad at him oh
they were yeah yeah they said you're
going you're going to go you did yeah
we're going to kill you off out of spite
yeah did you guys really not know that
they were killing him off until I knew a
little before but then nobody else knew
and then a lot of the reaction that the
people had on camera was reacting to you
know individualizing it was mcclain
knowing that like when they heard that
announcer you mcclain again yeah they
knew he wasn't going to come back on the
Christmas special there was going to be
nowhere to do it and I think he was
standing in the shadows in the back when
we did the scene I think it really
affected him while he was there yeah
also he didn't even know until he read
it or I don't know if he knew man have
you ever been killed off something where
they don't tell you you're going to be
killed off until uh no they told me they
told you they said I was doing blacklist
and Anna it was really going well and I
really loved working with Spader and he
we both enjoyed the
the interaction so they said ok this is
great we got to shows where you're
really heavy in and they start on Monday
I said well but the thing is on Monday I
start acting on Broadway in a play you
want me to come in during the day and
shoot the shows and no it's too much you
can't do it you got matinees you can't
do it come in Saturday and we'll blow
your head off
so and then we'll give the part to this
other guy we'll just change the name
that is that how they did it they blew
your head off yeah yeah if you love you
take the romance right out of it what
did you did you like your business yeah
you know sometimes they actually blow
your head off and this - this - we have
two minutes left with you Alan is
promoting if I understood you what I
have this look on my face and my
adventures in the arts of science of
relating communicating and when I read
of it it's really a good book and it's
really interesting the way you talk
about communicating and you're doing
something with Neil deGrasse Tyson at
the 92nd Street Y what is that yeah we
were talking about communication
when is that that's the 7th 6th or 7th
of June it's really up in a few here in
7th June 7th at the 92nd Street Y and
there may be a lot of fun that will be
amazingly hard to connect a world
science vegetable Tina Fey and I are
talking about communication well you are
at a meeting yeah we're talking
scientists I mean they're just there
they're scientists who can't communicate
like Neil deGrasse Tyson Michio cago
these are guys who are really good at
explaining things to people who aren't
scientists which is kind of nice because
somebody them can't talk and what's
wonderful for me personally is that I
realized while I was teaching scientists
that it applied to everybody and not
just scientists and that's what was
what's all over the book is how we all
can make use of that that this kind of
better communication works you know to
sit to put in the corner away from the
boardroom to the bedroom yeah before you
go always starting for a second first of
all it's not a question but you're
brilliant in the Aviator uh-huh but the
question is how do you have any of the
non questions of the Glitter feel free
how do you end up doing Horace and Pete
and what was the process
I was worried it was great I think my
agent suggested me to louis c.k and he
said he's nothing like this and she said
he can he's wonderful she can do
anything so I read it and it's such a
brilliant script
I talked with Louis and I said I'd
really like to be part of this and he
said would it's not you you're not him I
said well yeah I know but when I don't
know how I'm going to do something
that's like the best way to start that's
how I was with Hawkeye I didn't know I
didn't see myself as that character at
all but that makes you do something
original yeah you know so he said well
if you want to do it and you would know
best so okay I mean he's wonderful he's
he really takes a risk but it's amazing
too that he had balls enough like when
you were like interested he was like
well I don't know if you want to do this
like you would think yeah if you had
this project now and all the shows that
be like yeah I do it do it do it do it
do it no he is very concerned is very
interesting guys he's a kind of
improviser but he's also a master
planner he's a brilliant brilliant guy
I'm very glad to work with him yeah we
uh we have to wrap up with you also I
saw you in Glengarry Glen Ross when you
did that I wrote yeah as Shelley you
were fantastic thank you
all right I guess we have to wrap up the
book if I if I understood you what I
have this look on my feel it early one
of my favorite people in history so
thank you I didn't want it to interview
you and talk to you for probably 15
years I mean like get out all that so
you're finally and I'll mention the
appearances yeah although you got him
going into June 7th as we said he's with
Neil deGrasse Tyson at the 92nd Street Y
you can see Allan June 10th at Barnes &
Noble's in Union Square here in New York
at 2:00 p.m.
he's going to be in Los Angeles on June
12th and Atlanta on June 27th I didn't
even know about some of those things
yeah they tell us they never tell you
they regularly